reviewing god of war will now be in a
post god of war world so what do you
think keep it don't have a goatee and
have guyliner and be evil Jeremy yeah
we'll see what happens god of war so God
of War is half for the PlayStation 4
it's a sequel to God of War also a total
overhaul and revision of God award so
for dealing with Norse mythology now not
Greek mythologies that were before if
you remember Kratos his quest for
revenge and he pretty much wrapped that
up now he's hanging out doing the quiet
life his wife has died so he and his son
want to spread her ashes on the tallest
peak that's pretty much the gist of it
the big tail for revenge very personal
story with Kratos in his son granted
some gods do start getting in the way
there are a lot of monsters between
point A and point B actually point A to
point Z a lot of points in between takes
you through a few of the nine realms but
not all of the nine realms so you can
see all the nine realms you can't travel
to all nine realms and it really is an
overhaul if you just look at the
mechanics you have an axe that pretty
much acts like me linear you throw it
you can call it back to him but out the
gate the battle mechanics the camera
placement it's kind of over the shoulder
behind you it's completely different
than the other god of war game and that
was necessary I mean the other god of
war games it's a big tale for revenge
the gods have wronged create us now
Kratos was gonna kill him that's all fun
and dandy but if they were going that
route again there'd be no need for a new
game because that in and of itself is
pretty one dimension fun yes one
dimensional yeah this game has made
Kratos so much more complex its flesh
him out in ways that I didn't think
we're possible or even necessary I was
fine with Kratos being the Ghost of
Sparta that kick ass machine i always
knew him at I didn't know I wanted him
to be something else now that they have
added complexity to this degree in this
level I can't ever see me in my
perception of Kratos going back how did
I ever feel like Kratos so old was
enough there's a whole armor system in
here very action RPG element I like that
there were a couple times I was just go
up against two enemies and you get hit
twice ya die depending on the enemy this
is some other enemies you can take a few
hits you go up against one of the hard
ones though a couple good hits and
you're out so you really have to be more
calculating you can't just spam spam
spam spam spam spam spam spam spam not
like that most of the time you try to
charge headfirst into something you're
gonna get your ass kicked cuz Senate
race is a big part of it too there's a
couple different arrows he can equip you
level him up as well so pushing square
to stun lock enemies down then going at
them as cray
that's very important and the more the
game progresses the more dialogue there
is the more attach to get to a trace the
more important is to it was even a head
that's hanging off Kratos his belt
I liked him between head or what Kratos
just calls him head as he is in fact a
head at Reyes Kratos the dialogue
between all of them it keeps everything
going even in those moments where you
just all right I'm rowing there's a
story happening there's dialogue
happening not only flushes out the realm
and the lore but it also flushes out the
characters and if you like the lore I
like the mythology I mean that's one of
the things I liked about the old god of
war game you learn some fun Greek
mythology from God of War now you learn
some fun Norse mythology from God or it
does change your perception on Norse
mythology because a lot of Norse
mythology I'll be honest with you it
came from the MCU for me why the [ __ ]
would I need to know anything about Thor
ever in my life except for the Thor I
see on screen but this totally paints
that world Thor Odin in a very different
light and you remember oh yeah it's
mythology in mythology gods are dicks oh
just generally they're [ __ ]
there's a lot to explore in this game
though like I said in Norse mythology
there are nine realms you don't travel
to all nine realms it teases you and
shows you that there are nine realms but
it's like it's been locked off Odin has
locked that off which makes me think
it's probably they'll say I guess
there's no plans to have a season pass
for DLC so is it for DLC or is it just
setting up for a sequel I mean it's
logical even if you don't go to all of
the realms in this story that the rums
would still exist so I get that they
would still show it to you it was
showing you something that you can't
experience this makes you feel like
you're missing out on something like
going to Baskin Robbins 31 flavors is
like yeah here are five of the flavors
and you're not 31 flavors at that point
you are five I like the armor system in
this game a little word of advice bump
up your luck and again don't have an
alternative I'm just saying bumping up
my luck seemingly helped me out I got a
lot of life more gold than I needed more
than enough XP to max out everything
maybe bumping my luck stat had nothing
to do with that any it did there is a
lot to explore a lot of treasures I will
say Kratos is now officially a better
treasure hunter than Nathan Drake I
found more treasures with Kratos than I
ever did is Nathan Drake there's a bit
more backtracking than I tend to like in
games like this it's like all the waters
went down now we can go there and you
scramble around get some stuff but you
can't get everything because you don't
have everything yet you have to come
back when you get another ability I
almost feel like it would have saved me
more time just to be like I'm not
exploring anywhere until I get
everything in terms of abilities rather
going back to areas after getting every
new abilities wait till you get all the
abilities and you can just go there once
I will say this game kind of ends on a
bit of an anticlimactic note and what I
mean by that is usually in a game like
this when I'm coming up on the boss you
could totally feel that it's the boss
but I fight this dude and I'm like
alright this is clearly not the boss
turns out it was and then the game was
over had no idea if you look at that
fight and that wrap up as just the wrap
up for this game I might sell you a
little short but if you look at it as
setup as to what may be coming that's
where it may have a lot more gravity to
it God of War is a very heavy journey a
very emotional journey is actually
heavier than I ever thought I want to
God a war to be I didn't know I wanted
this game and then now I play it I'm
like how did I live without it there's
actually a moment in this game where
someone gets sick in terms of emotional
cinematic game moments it's up there
it's one at the top for me guys in the
end god of war is an emotional epic it's
not an epic of vengeance it's not an
epic of slaughter there are some great
kills that happened with some monsters
in this game but it's icing on the cake
it's not the point Kratos and this god
of war game treats Kratos has passed
very very realistically I think he got
his revenge before his life's not better
in fact he's not really proud of that
whole thing I thought this very profound
is very powerful this game justifies its
own existence in terms of characters
plot and gameplay
it keeps the kick-ass for you liked
about God of War though it is refined to
be a little more purposeful and focused
in terms of battle mechanic but this
greatest strength is in what the old god
of war games didn't have that is
emotional weight they've hit the
Goldilocks zone or God of War I can't
wait to see a sequel because I really
feel like this game does set up for that
I was like God of War is awesome tacular
I didn't even play it on a pro I play it
on my regular ps4 my like launched a ps4
looked fantastic the graphics in this
game are insanity wares of God of War
have you played it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
liked what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here just say
more
[Music]